- AMAZING.
- SO HOT.
- GOT LIKE FOUR STARS SOMEWHERE.
- I HEARD IT GOT SIX STARS,
WHICH IS, LIKE,
IMPOSSIBLE.
- OH, MY GOD.
LET'S TAKE A PICTURE.
- LET'S TAKE A PICTURE RIGHT
NOW. OH, MY GOD, HERE WE GO.
[camera snaps]
- OH, MY GOD, I'M MAKING A FACE.
- OH, MY GOD, I'M, LIKE,
ONE BIG NOSE. DELETE IT.
- EW, DELETE IT.
- [scoffs]
[camera snaps]
- EW.
- WHAT AM I DOING? I'M GROSS.
- HOW COME I LOOK
LIKE AN ORCA WHALE?
- DELETE IT.
[gun fires, screaming]
- ON THE GROUND.
- OH, MY GOD.
WE'RE GETTING ROBBED.
- OH, MY GOD, OH, MY GOD,
OH, MY GOD, OH, MY--
OH, MY GOD,
WHAT'S MY EYE DOING?
- EW, I LOOK LIKE I'M 40.
DELETE IT.
- OH, MY GOD.
- LET'S GET OUT OF HERE,
BUT DELETE IT.
- GET DOWN! DOWN!
[camera snaps]
- OH, MY GOD, I LOOK LIKE
SOMEBODY UNWRAPPED A MUMMY.
- GOD, I LOOK LIKE
A FIVE-YEAR-OLD DREW ME.
- TOTALLY DELETE IT.
- DELETE IT.
- RIGHT?
- FREEZE!
[gunshots]
- EW, I TOTALLY LOOK
LIKE CLOVERFIELD.
- DID I JUST HAVE
A STROKE OR SOMETHING?
both: DELETE IT.
- RIGHT?
- YEAH.
[gun fires]
- L-LADIES,
CAN YOU JUST SHOW ME
THE PICTURE
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT, PLEASE?
- OH, IT'S LIKE--
- YEAH, STOP.
GREAT, RIGHT THERE.
[laughs] THAT'S GREAT.
G-GRADY, WE GOT A CLEAR SHOT
OF THE PERPETRATOR.
HE'S HOLDING A SHOTGUN
AND EVERYTHING.
WAI-WAIT, WAIT,
WHERE'D THE PICTURE GO?
- WE DELETED IT.
- GROSS.
- WHAT?
- I HAD CHILDBIRTH FACE.
- YEAH, IT LOOKED LIKE
MY GRANDMOTHER HAVING AN ORGASM.
- DELETE IT.
- GRADY, BOOK THESE IDIOTS
FOR DESTROYING EVIDENCE.
- OW.
EW.
WHY ARE YOU BEING
SO "MANHANDLY"?
- I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS.
WHY ARE WE EVEN--
WE WERE THE HEROES
OF THE EVENING.
- RIDICULOUS.
- WE STOPPED THE PERPETRATOR.
NOW WE'RE BEING ARRESTED?
- CAN WE PLEASE--
OH, MY GOD,
THESE COPS SHOULD BE ARRESTED.
- THIS IS A MISCARRIAGE
OF JUSTICE, THE ENTIRE TH--
[both gasp]
- WHAT?
NO [bleep] WAY.
- OH, MY GOD, YOU CANNOT--
- DELETE IT.
- YOU CANNOT ARREST ME
WITH THAT PICTURE.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
- DELETE IT.
- I WAS BLINKING.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
- DELETE IT.
- DELETE IT RIGHT NOW.
DELETE IT.
YOU MUST DELETE THIS PHOTO.
- DELETE IT. NO.
- DELETE IT.
I'M NOT LEAVING
UNTIL HE DELETES IT.
- HE HAS A PICTURE OF US.
DELETE IT.
- I'M NOT LEAVING UNTIL HE--
YOU GOTTA DELETE IT!
YOU'VE GOTTA DELETE IT.
- JUST DELETE IT.
- YOU HAVE TO DELETE THIS PIC--
- DELETE IT!